I love this guy's one of my favorite
guests that we've ever had in the five
plus year of doing this show you could
see him on ESPN on get up and as a
Thursday night college football analyst
his show is on YouTube his own in
Westwood won every single day from 10:00
a.m. the noon eastern time and he is the
last losing punter in a Miami Super Bowl
this is an incredible setup you had to
mention the last Super Bowl here in
Miami well I mean I
I'm just spitting facts I mean I figured
you you know if there's an elephant in
the room you just got to address it yeah
otherwise it could be really awful
I talked to Drew Brees this morning yeah
he was just stopping he was just here's
hurry because right here stone street
was here you know they stacked lineup
the Rich Eisen show brings out all the
best in people were in a parking garage
in Miami
it is 700 degrees and you have a packed
house rich this is a beautiful beautiful
car these are all facts did you breathe
we had a 20-minute conversation we
settled the beef of what he did to me
when I was 22 years old what did he do
to you
well him and that stupid baby I told you
about it they were up on that Jumbotron
as I was walking off the field yeah and
I was a rookie and I've talked to you
about this before but please for those
who might not know refresh we want 14 to
know that year I was drafted to play
alongside not alongside I was on the
same team to Peyton Manning I was just
kind of being dragged along excuse me
you were providing Peyton Manning with
the premium field position which he
could dominate not really I just don't
get punning yeah I was not good okay
Poli and when he drafted me to punt
literally said we think you're athletic
enough to figure it out I was like well
damn we're gonna find out aren't we pal
and I wasn't but we made the Super Bowl
which tells you all you need to know
about punting yeah but as I was walking
off that field and that was the best
team I've ever been a part of still to
this day that rookie here we went 14
though we didn't lose until we chose to
lose that we made the run through the
playoffs then were you obviously
ultimately lose to Drew Brees for a lot
of different reasons a lot of people get
blamed for that loss I am NOT one of
them so that is okay with me
but as I was walking off of the field
and drew brees and his baby or up on
that Jumbotron and confetti was flying
just I walked into the most miserable
locker room I've ever been in my entire
life does whenever you lose people are
upset but after that Super Bowl loss I
had never walked into a collective group
of humans that were that miserable and I
was like guys no big deal we'll just
come back next year guys don't worry
about it
we'll come back the year after that then
the year after that we'll do this every
single February this will be something
we just do and then we never made it
back in three years later we are almost
completely defeated with Curtis Painter
Terry Collins and Dan Orlovsky as a
quarterback yes and then Andrew Luck
came to town and we were close but we
never made it back and that's why these
games are so special because you altima
and I think the Patriots have trying to
debunk this theory it is very very hard
to get to the Super Bowl
so everybody talking about how loaded
this Chiefs team is and how young and
great this 49ers team is and I'd agree
with both of those things it is very
hard to get this Super Bowl I was only
at one I was 22 I was intoxicated for
most of the week and then the only thing
I remember is a Drew Brees and his baby
took all of her happiness and we never
made it back and then that baby is the
one he just brought with them into the
Pro Bowl as I think is an 11 year old
now Lamar Jackson it's amazing out of
time flies that kids more athletic than
I am career than I am
and I think the thing about talking
about beylin breeze you're talking about
labor Ward Lamar Jackson well he yeah
okay obvious understand what the hell
was going on
is there a concert happening in sparking
drug this is its energy pad it's synergy
no that's not the name of the band
there's a Sunday Ticket an NFL Sunday
Ticket sort of space behind us there's
be our gridiron over in the corner okay
and then there's Dan Patrick show that
is being broken down right now cuz he's
done for the week well and then there's
us but we're alive with you right now
and then by the way I'll use this as a
moment to tease the fact that you're
gonna stick around through the break and
kick off the next out damn right I yes
in which let me make sure I get this
right because I
read these names a guy named two of who
I've heard of yep nailed it
he's good at the football his dad tied
his arm to his body he became a lefthand
sir true story so he has been dominant
in college football with his wrong hand
did your dad tie you tired leg now he
tied me to a fence you remember this
[Laughter]
played soccer growing up but I flinched
and he take me to a fence and threw
balls at me and said it's not that bad
is it the duct tape just ripped all the
hair off my arm and then Deontay Wilder
stops by later on an hour oh he's a
tough guy
he's he's good at the boxing hey what do
they call him the bomber bomb squad
that's right bomber right yeah now let's
get to the poll question what I want to
get to because as you know in the radio
business these are reeds and these are
sponsors that are associated with parts
of the program
yeah a little behind the scenes it's
right let's you know how the sausage
gets made Capital One is reimagined
banking by offering savings and checking
accounts with no fees or minimums one of
the nation's best savings rates Capital
One what's in your wallet ask Pat the
poll question our final poll question of
the week here what does Capital One
doing no fees no fees no minimum money
hey Pat breaking news the Superbowl is
in two days two days what's gonna happen
Chiefs win big Chiefs win close 49ers
big or 49ers in a close one I think the
Chiefs win by more than one and a half
that
now that's odd that you would give us
that total a spread like I've never seen
half points on a board what are you
talking I'm or than one and a half that
might be my bank account
I told us that notice that mean your
bank account goes over well is that what
you're saying - no rich whenever I
retired they told me I'm gonna have to
save my money yeah but I thought a good
way to make all the money that I made
kicking would be gambling on the sport
that I know so much about in this
particular football season has been very
kind to me
I've done very well very very well on
FanDuel I've done very very well okay
but this Super Bowl I am taking
everything that I've won yes and I am
doubling down I am James Holzhauer on
Jeopardy Double or Nothing putting it
all in and I put it on the Chiefs - one
and a half and I feel very good about it
to be honest with you I feel fair my mom
is gonna hate this conversation by the
way because the fact I'm wearing
sunglasses in here she's gonna think I'm
either on some vitamins or hungover
it's just because there is a light
there's lights everywhere right we're in
a parking garage - this guy knows look
at those glasses of course I'm wearing
them but everything's got it why would
you think that your mom would think that
you're on some sort of supplements yeah
what's some sort of size so what you're
talking about you're talking about
making sure that your your vitamin D is
is its vitamins T vitamin H and C my
mother my mother doesn't know much about
the journalism world she only has a
couple rules big J big J my eyes know
much about it she only has a couple
rules okay don't false quote somebody
sure and don't wear sunglasses on TV but
it's very bright and it is Miami I will
say what's your mom's name
Sally Sally I'm addressing camera now as
I marry Sally
he seems very reasonable it's just very
bright in here and I do like the look
that you got going on right now Pat you
I think you gelled up just specifically
for this appearance if I'm not mistaken
or is that you did that for the ESPN
appearance give me the 5 a.m. for get up
but it
for this show I redid it while walking
in level yeah our buddy Brian from LA
the Chiefs fan right there there's a few
more
okay so stay right where you are if you
don't mind let's do it awesome kick back
there we go
a fun first hour Eric Stonestreet was
here and then drew brees stopped by and
Christian McCaffrey came by and then
America's Sweetheart Pat McAfee is here
no no no no hey look nobody showed up
with for the brand apparel and a flag
like this dude did and then when we come
back to and Deontay Wilder will also be
here at Pat McAfee our one in the books
of our last day our number two of day
number five here at the Miami Honda
studio we are on floor number seven of a
parking garage hanging out with Pat
McAfee which is exactly how I want to be
where else would I rather be than right
here right now good to see you who's
better than us huh No
and later on in this hour to a tongue go
vile Oh we'll be stopping by Deontay
Wilder the WBC heavyweight champion will
be here as well our three will finish
things up with Chris Brockman giving us
an one final Super Bowl news update and
then Joe Perot Heisman Trophy winner
National Champion and first overall pick
of the upcoming draft as we all expect
him to be he will be here Eric
Stonestreet was here to kick off our
show drew brees just popped in and just
hung out and then Pat McAfee stopped by
after Christian McCaffrey if you missed
all or any of that go to our YouTube
page to check things out did I do that
right past you nailed it you know you
nailed it well that's where people check
out the Pat Mac if he shows how am i
right I've become a youtuber over the
last couple months and although I might
have been embarrassed of that in the
past no very proud of the fact that we
are youtubers you and I okay so people
can go follow the Pat McAfee show on
their YouTube page the Rich Eisen show
on our YouTube page these people serious
honking like this doodle boy the middle
of you too bad we are
okay it has been non-stop all week but
just hop you know we've been up here
it's been great what goes on in the
street down there it's not I mean it's
nonstop sorry never seen cocaine Cowboys
that isn't that isn't that is that Billy
Corbin's Yeah right yeah yeah he's our
Miami guys you know yeah Griselda's not
down there right now though I mean what
does go on eating down there you rip but
any rate we're thrilled to be up here by
the way makes a lot of sense yes the
Honda studio in a parking garage see
look at that
you know what's energy poor my car brand
right here on the Rich Eisen show I
appreciate that you can watch by the way
DirecTV 4k is how you can watch the big
game coming up on Sunday night DirecTV
is the leader in 4k live sports and with
4k you get nearly four times the display
resolution of HD an immersive home
viewing experience you get to watch live
sports like never before and if you
don't have 4k go to att.com/paybill
Arjun factual okay why do you think that
I just think in 2020 and I said this
earlier to Matt Patricia on my show that
2020 I feel like the way the rules are
in the NFL okay whether it's for safety
whether it's for fantasy football
whatever it is I feel as if the rules of
the game right now
are slighted towards the offense and I
understand that back in the day defense
won championships I think that's a very
accurate statement for back in the day
but now I feel like if you have a great
offense with the way the game is set up
I think you can win any game that you
could possibly want to win and five of
the last seven Super Bowls have hit the
over okay last Super Bowl was such a dud
such a dud that everybody forgets that
normally any Super Bowls a lot of points
are scored and for me I just think the
potentially the most lethal offense in
the history the
NFL taking on this dominant defense in
the year 2020
I think the Patrick mahomes and the boys
are just gonna be too much but I could
see how the Niners could win it's gonna
be close that's why I picked him the win
by at least one and a half and it's
interesting we had Warren Sapp here on
Monday and he said years ago when we
were doing NFL gameday morning together
defense is no longer wins you
championship he says defense gives you a
chance offense wins you championships is
what he said you have to have a
powerhouse on the offense inside the
ball I think it's just become that style
of play everything's become quicker you
know now granted Lamar Jackson has kind
of taken that back right there
ground-and-pound but they're still
putting up a lot of points in the
offense still controls that play I just
think we live in an offensive world and
to me it'd be very very cool to see Andy
Reid get that massive monkey off his
back and while doing so leading the
Kansas City Chiefs to the Super Bowl for
the first time in 50 years and also
getting a win I just think all cards are
kind of set towards that but from what
chef Tortola Cooney many sources he said
that the Chiefs team is very confident
and they feel as if they already got it
that kind of scares me a little bit but
I think that's how they operate
I think the Niners defense is going to
be you know a hell of a show but I do
think that she's got it Pat McAfee here
on the Rich Eisen show and it's it's I'm
finally here on Friday and I'm just
gonna let myself go I think and I said
this in brockman gave me you've been
holding off for this is the most
talented quarterback that's ever played
in the Super Bowl this does Terry
Bradshaw know that you said this I
didn't say he's the witness I didn't say
he's the winningest or that he's I say
he's the most talented that brings a
skill set that nobody else has had from
the arm from the legs from a neck up
from everything well Kurt Warner well
Curt Kent couldn't hurt couldn't escape
the pocket like Mook mo home you say
Kurt Warner's a slow old white guy I
didn't say that you just said that his
nickname he likes to tell us was named
Houdini but yeah when he was in 1999 he
couldn't escape the pocket like like
Holmes can Jonny I could segment that
way could throw it like mahomes and
Elway could run it like my Holmes you
could say Elway is is something who used
to planting but in Elway was Elway when
he yeah yeah I mean you you can make
that case but your consisteth young who
I'm gonna be with on the honor stage
tomorrow night Aaron Rodgers did you
turn arena Aaron Rodgers and what about
Aaron Rodgers I'm not saying I'm right
[Laughter]
and the reason why I'm saying this is I
just think that it's mahomes his moment
that Sunday night's mahomes his moment
in some of the plays that we see like
the Wow flipping it with his left hand
the Wow he's running around 15 yards
here and then twelve yards there and
throws it like on a line to slip back
part of the endzone on a frozen rope he
does that in front of 120 million
Americans on Sunday and we're gonna
start talking about him in the manner in
which I'm currently on and how about he
does everything you're saying and then
throws it 75 yards on a rope to Tyree
killed busting through that cover great
like all of the mahomes things that
we've seen him do in his first year and
a half or year and 3/4 his starter you
know obviously III he missed three games
this year that's what I'm saying it's
year three right for him now the first
year I would have loved to seeing him on
a practice squad by the way I couldn't
even fathom what he was like in practice
against that Kansas City Chiefs defense
they had to be like like when it finally
got his chance to play against the
Broncos I believe the last week and that
really season it wet his beak in week 16
of his rookies which by the way was
autumn Utley the reason why Andy Reed
decided to keep him and let Alex Smith
go Alex Smith is back next year by the
way let's remember that but whenever
they let Alex Smith go everybody's very
confused I like to think of the Kansas
City Chiefs defenders that were just
getting cooked by Patrick mahomes all
like 15 week said that or whatever and
then finally the next year when he comes
out and becomes MVP they're like I tried
saying this guy you're next he is
unbelievable
yeah he's absolutely unbelievable
everything you just said he's 100%
accurate watching the only the only
thing I think that could slow him down
is if he gets a little tight right sure
anybody that plays that loose and that
style but it looks like whenever they're
down 24 nothing they're down 10 nothing
in these biggest moments
he's like a maestro to the crowd he's
feeling and he's vibing and he's
Showtime it's real I think on that big
stage he's gonna show up and show out
and I think Andy Reid also had some new
play designs that he beautiful minded on
a dry erase board that he's gonna be
able to really make some magic happen to
Pat McAfee of the Pat McAfee show ESPN
and more right here on the Rich Eisen
show you tweeted out today that you saw
shefter sending out an email that said
Tom Brady on it was a subject line okay
now Brady is here in Florida apparently
was golfing yesterday my play for the
Dolphins next year I don't know about
that I think I think he's gonna be here
as part of the NFL 100 all-time team
celebration that's part of the Super
Bowl and all sorts of stuff so are you
at that I'm not I'm gonna be at the
Super Bowl yeah but I don't think I'm
part of the NFL 100 all-time team's
thing me neither they shame like how did
you know they did by the way let clear
and where a guy made it yeah I'm
indifferent unrig I know you are
what does he slided you one day on his
award yeah you know how to give you the
Heisman me down for the Ray Guy Award
you know in college right and out of the
the nation's punters we weren't the
right three finalists right we weren't
the right three but out of the three
finalists I was clearly the winner had
to rent a suit for this thing my mom and
dad had a call off work we go down to
Orlando sit through all this crap and he
gives the award to somebody he was
friends with and I'm like you know what
ray guys dead to me so lame guy out
shame Leclerc in I love shame like when
I talked to him by the way you said me
say and I'm not saying I'm right was
your favorite thing you've heard me say
ray guys dead to me maybe the favorite
thing I've ever heard I mean that shame
like Raziel but in terms of brady man he
put up a photograph on his social media
feeds that's kind of the laurel yani of
photographs where you're trying to
figure we all look at it or and see
something different it's so imply that
dress okay exactly it's that type of
version of a post of him we assume
that's Gillette is he in your mind
walking into Gillette which we would all
assume meaning he's going to stay a
patriot or do you think this is a
photograph of him
leaving Gillette and we all read into
the fact that he's leaving the Patriots
Pat McAfee your thoughts can I please
say that I love everything Tom Brady has
done his postgame press conferences his
social media this season press
conference wrap up press conference
everything he's done has been cerebral
and deliberate okay setting him up for
this opportunity that he hasn't had for
20 years his social media team is second
to none and I have a good social media
team his social media team is very
intelligent very bright and they've made
Tom Brady look like a relatable human
and he's an alien
he's an alien so I think his social
media team is absolutely credible this
if you live on the internet for any time
you know that you're a detective you're
an investigator you have to look up
other photos Tom Brady wears his watch
on his left hand okay it is very clear
that he's wearing a very massive
expensive watch on his left hand he is
walking into that Stadium but but who
says that isn't from a commercial saying
sometimes you got to take one last trip
home before you hit that this isn't just
going to be more of these calibrated
cerebral string people alongside pose
from Tom Brady and I wouldn't I wouldn't
expect the Superbowl commercial to be
any different because the guy has played
this thing perfectly and that's why he's
that goat on the field and now he's the
goat and free agent where he's wearing
this you don't see the watch on the
proper hand here and that looks like to
me like he's walking out of that
statement
I mean his left his foot that's on his
left foot at if he if he's walking out
of the stadium or his right if he's
walking in that foot looks like it is
been picked up like he is walking out
man choose what's going out of the
stadium to me that does not look like
that foot is being lifted up to walk in
that would be very odd sort of fight
opposition Tom Brady does things just an
alien right but two or three weeks ago
on the internet I don't Brock might soon
as TJ prime saw it there was a guy on a
swing as you see this and you didn't
know if you're swinging towards the
building or swinging away from the
building and everybody like you took
over that captivated the internet yeah
just like this has just I believe the
detectives of the internet they say they
think he's walking in here with the
watch opportunity
but I think this is gonna play into a
bigger play that's still gonna string
people along and have no idea and
ultimately leave New England Patriots
fans completely befuddled about the
entire situation Chris what are you for
I just tweeted out with this picture
yesterday WTF is this cuz I it was just
screwing with everybody's mind
I love and Curran said the same thing
he's just Epping with us right now he's
just having fun with all of it is it not
perfect though it's / it's just like tom
has been playing the last couple of
seasons well then he goes that fight
talks to a guy with the terrible haircut
all of a sudden bang he's going to Las
Vegas Raiders right then now he's down
here in Miami for the top 100 team all
he's got to do is what DAP up Brian
Flores one time oh he's a quarterback of
the Dolphins he has played this thing
perfectly he could end up at like seven
different teams and everybody would be
like that that makes sense there's a
rumor yesterday he was in Tennessee
looking at houses and schools yeah this
is crazy
yeah that starts Monday by the way
congrats whoever wins the Super Bowl you
get about four hours of celebration
because Monday morning is where is Tom
Brady going what did I say to you about
the fourth storyline of the week would
be above Jimmy G it would be Tom Brady's
future and again you know we hear on
this show now how you you you if you
enjoy busting the balls of your your
fellow mates on the air and I'm hats all
we do okay we do it with each other
about being somewhat hypocritical so I
ask you sir mr. Brockman what if JJ Watt
had posted a photograph just like this
one two days before the man who knew he
was reported to have demanded to be sent
out of town to maintain his space on his
team in New England what if JJ Watt had
tweeted out this just right at the end
of that super strap what would you say
what you said all this attention-seeking
guys that would you would have said
Brock how many are rings this JJ Watt
have response it's a great response
really good hey by the way Jimmy G wins
he has three Super Bowl rings that's
what I hear sweet him who Terry Bradshaw
no Terry Bradshaw has got four he's got
what he's got four he best Peyton
Manning
and Eli Manning and Ben Roethlisberger
Drew Brees McAfee do you never mean what
were you doing before it before I let
you go sir what were you doing the
Friday before the Super Bowl in Miami 10
years ago - oh we had a lockdown early
in the week though we hit it we had
Peyton Manning at us out the first night
we landed it was like Sunday or Monday
and forget which one it was took us out
to a dinner and then we kind of had a
couple drinks afterwards and then
Tuesday I went out with the defense that
was a much different evening you know
and then Wednesday we kind of locked it
down all the way through and I was on a
very veteran led team so trying to lead
by example but got the partying out of
the way early and then we kind of tried
to focus as much as we possibly could on
the biggest game of our light of my life
and ultimately we lost and yeah I mean
this city stinks I like the city it's
really good oh my god it's funny when Al
Jarreau my Rich Eisen show research it
gives me a card about everybody's
accolades and things that you see things
that you do you have so many of things
that's going on with you Pat I'm so
thrilled with what you have made
yourself and what you are college
football analyst on Thursday night a for
ESPN you're on get up the Pat McAfee
show on YouTube - zone and Westwood 1:10
a.m. the noon eastern every single day
you've got your pod to write the Pat
McAfee showed 2.0 they own it got going
on yeah and then eight seasons in the
NFL two-time Pro Bowler first-team
all-pro AFC champion in 2000 oh hold on
a minute
college football at West Virginia this
is what it says first-team all-american
2008 thank you Ray guy finalists 2008
that's a story that's at the very bottom
of ray guys dead to me but the hunter of
the decade to please punter the decade
from the pro Football Focus hey those
numbers don't lie I comments where it's
no slouch and they funny and the people
that they got with the slide rules
they're saying this with the Pro
Football Focus yeah judging defense and
offense is difficult because you don't
know what everybody's responsibilities
are on each play ok so you don't know if
the Safety's supposed to cover for a
corner or not so they might get that
wrong
yeah kicking and punting is pretty
clear-cut pro Football Focus looks at
every single rep they don't lie I don't
know hunter of not the day not the week
not the month not the year not a year no
ten of them
[Applause]
whoever drops you is a buffoon and
you're gonna strive and crush because
your team is great your show is great
I've been watching you since I was a kid
thank you so much for having me I mean
this miserable heat right in this
parking garage in the absent pests at
Pat McAfee show on Twitter and Instagram
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app